*Musique*
*catastrophe en approche*
Je vais parler politique
Woh !!!
Owowowo ok on se calme
On est pas là pour dire pour qui il faut voter dans x année
On là est parce qu'aujourd'hui, j'ai envie qu'on fasse une petite rétrospective
de tout les moments de politique en France qui nous on fait kiffer.
Pas ce qui ont été très très connu les 3,4 dernières années, qui sont mêmes devenu des memes comme :
"PARCE QUE C'EST NOTRE PROJET !!!"
Ou encore :
"Ils sont dans les campagnes, dans les villes."
Ou même :
*musique Inception*
Non, non, non ça on l'a déjà trop vu et aujourd'hui on est là pour voir des moments similaires mais qui sont plus vieux
donc que vous n'avez pas vu mais qui sont tout autant géniaux.
Attention je précise les amis on est pas là pour parler de ses opinions politiques
Pour ce qui en ont, il n'y a plein qui n'en ont pas d'ailleurs
On est juste là pour voir des gens qui sont mystifiés
Parce qu'ils représentent un pays et on attends d'eux qu'ils se comportent mais comme les meilleurs des hommes
qu'ils nous fassent surtout pas honte
mais des fois ça foire, et moi c'est ces moments là que je veux voir aujourd'hui
c'est ces moments où ça a chié il y a un truc qu'est allé de travers. Et c'est ça qui me fait rire
Nous allons commencer avec Chirac, avec Jacques Chirac
putain je parle comme si c'était mon pote c'est horrible
Quel homme fort on dirait mon grand-père
Premier truc drôle avec J.Chirac
la fois où il était dans le public de la coupe du monde
le public criait les noms des joueurs un à un
Et J.Chirac voulait lui aussi avoir se plaisir de crier le nom des joueurs
Sauf qui connaissait pas trop les noms J.Chirac
AHAH
Au début on peut croire qu'il dit le nom mais pas du tout
Il fait vraiment ça :
et ça passe sur tout les noms
La, il connaissait
La il connaissait pas ! On l'a vu !
ZIDANE
Pardon. Putain je suis à fond dedans
Oh non Chirac ! Non !
Tu ne peux pas, ça ne marche pas dans la vie. Quand tu ne connais pas un mot ne rien dire et juste à la dernière syllabe faire :
Comme si tu l'avais crié
Si on met un micro devant ta bouche on entend juste ça
HHHHEEEE
ça ne marche pas Jacques !
Alors ? Ah oui, alors celle la elle est exceptionnelle
Je l'avais vu à l'époque.
Chirac est un homme qui aime les femmes
Comme beaucoup d'homme ! Est-ce qu'on lui on veut pour ça ?
Bernadette Chirac devait faire un discours devant des gens. Je sais pas pour quelle occasion, je sais pas dans quel but.
mais bon voila elle devais faire un discours donc Jacques était assis derrière elle et y'a une
dame, jeune qui ne trouvais pas de place pour s'asseoir donc Chirac trouvait ça scandaleux qu'elle n'ait pas de place pour s'asseoir et il a
insisté pour qu'elle s’assoit à coté de lui et ce qui se passe en suite est ... *bruit de bouche* fabuleux.
"mesdames et messieux les élus , mes chers collègues,..." (disours de mme chirac)
(chuchotements de Mr Chirac)
ha ha ha ha
elle le reprend vraiment au calme devant tout le monde regardez y'a ma veine qui commence a sortir
c'est que j'apprecis vraiment ce moment voila c'est un indicateur d'appreciation de moment ca
cette tête jacques, on l'a déjà tous fait quand on avait 9 ans , qu'on copiait sur le voisin et que le prof' nous prend
en train de copier sur le voisin, Mais tu l'a fait a 60 piges , C'EST DRÔLE !!!
Jacques , si tu regarde cette vidéo euhhh bah abonne toi hein ...
Débat présidentiel, Chirac est face a Mitterrand, Mitterrand qui sort de son quinquennat, Jacques Chirac qui est le premier ministre
qu'est ce que Jacques Chirac dira a Mitterrand ce moment la ?
- "Permettez moi juste de vous dire que ce soir , je ne suis pas le premier ministre, et vous n’êtes pas le Président de la République,
nous sommes deux candidats, à égalité et qui se soumettent au jugement des français, le seul qui compte , vous me permettrez donc
de vous appeler monsieur Mitterrand"
- "Mais vous avez tout a fait raison monsieur le PREMIER MINISTRE !"
*bruit de vuvuzela*
ha ha ha ha !  Meilleur réponse, il a très bien répondu. les hommes politiques ils ont une impro...
enfin, a l’époque en tout cas, maintenant c'est un peu moins ouf je trouve quand on regarde
mais je trouve que ça par exemple c'est vraiment..., c'est un clash quoi
genre limite y'a pas un gars avec un panneau ROUND 1 et le but c'est de sortir la plus grosse punchline pour faire le plus gros buzz et avoir le plus de voix
Ça me fait rire! , bon il y a eu énormément d'autres moments ou Jacques Chirac a fait des folies mais ca c'est les videos principales et
ce qui est bien en voyant ça c'est qu'on a un peu moins peur de vieillir, on espère dans 20-30 ans parler de cette manière, avoir ce… charisme !
hé hé
deuxièmement nous allons passer a Sarkozy , à monsieur Nicolas Sarkozy...
et alors lui il a aussi fait des trucs mec c'est fou il y en a des millions
"ENCULE !!!"
bah si je descend je te met un coup de boule donc heu vaut mieux pas
*rires*
Il est vé-ner, "Viens là la castagne, tu vas voir ! Je suis président ! "
"Si tu crois que c'est en insultant que tu vas régler le problème des pécheurs…"
Bon, ceci dit il a pas tord sur la deuxième partie de sa phrase heu… Insulter ne résous aucun problème. Vraiment.
Une fois, j'ai insulté ma maman, eh bah vraiment le problème a été décuplé !
Vidéo suivante, il s'agit d'un vol de stylo apparemment
*voix de la vidéo* "Notre président et sa collection bling-bling qui grossit à vue d'œil,
il avait déjà les chaînes en or, les grosses montres, l'alliance, et lundi en Roumanie,
il n'a pas résisté en signant un partenariat stratégique, regardez bien,
"hmm… Eh pas mal le stylo qui brille !"
Il le repose, il revient dessus, le prend, demande au président roumain, et hop !
Un truc bling-bling de plus dans la poche !"
Bah il a raison mec, moi j'aurais fait pareil avec un stylo-plume Poivre Blanc
Ah bah moi en classe, la trousse elle était pas grosse comme ça pour rien hein...
Le moment le plus connu ou Sarko' c'est foiré en public c'est après le G8,
C'est à dire c'est un rassemblement de 8 pays pour discuter des échanges économiques, etc... entre eux
Sarkozy vient de rencontrer Poutine, la rencontre a duré je crois 1 ou 2 heures
Et en sortant de la rencontre, il fait un discours devant des journalistes français qui lui disent "Alors avec la Russie, on est comment ?"
"Est ce que nos relations vont être biens ?", etc...
Et Sarko', est complètement… torché.
Tout le monde se dit "Ah bah c'est Poutine, la Russie, la Vodka, ça y est il a descendu des trucs Sarko' hein…"
Regardez, écoutez c'est impressionnant
"Je vous demande de bien excusez mon retard… Qui est dû *se racle la gorge*
à la longueur du dialogue que je vient d'avoir avec Mr. Poutine"
*silence*
"Qu'est ce que vous préférez ? Que je réponde aux questions ?
Alors...
Y'a t - il des questions ? *rire*
Allez y
Oui oui, bah oui"
*silence*
*Squeezie reprend la parole* Y'a un documentaire qui sorti plus tard sur ça, qui revenait sur cette rencontre entre Sarkozy et Poutine
et qui expliquait en fait Sarkozy a la sortie de la rencontre il avait, ils avaient pas du tout bu les deux
il était pas du tout bourré
Sauf que Poutine, l'avait remis à sa place mais avec une force monumental !
Sarkozy parlait à Poutine un peu d'un air hautain, sûr de lui, blablabla
Bah Poutine, ça l'a un peu saoulé. Et Poutine a regardé Sarko, il lui a dit :
"Ecoute moi bien mec. Ton pays c'est ça, mon pays c'est ça. Donc maintenant tu vas commencer à changer de ton sinon je vais t'écraser." *rires*
Et du coup il était comme ça pendant le discours.
Donc sachez, que si vous vous faites très fortement humilier, quand vous parlez après, vous ressemblez à ça
Donc peut être, marquez une pause de 30 minutes entre l'humiliation et le moment où vous parlez, pour voilà. Eviter de vivre ça
*en chantant* FRANCOIS HOLLANDE ! Président de 2012 à 2017 !
Alors déjà lui, il représente parfaitement, le niveau d'anglais, moyen, que les français ont.
Non mais vraiment !
C'est un tel cliché ! Ca méritait d'être président 5 ans
*bruit de grillons*
*en pleine galère d'anglais*
Il s'adresse à Elon Musk, gros ! Notre Dieu à tous !
*encore en pleine galère d'anglais*
*rires*
Bon les gars, est ce qu'on peut en vouloir à Hollande ? Arrêtez, on fait tous çaaaa
"Do you have euh…. euh… serviette ?"
Quand le mot y sort pas, et qu'il y a le moment de silence qui se prolonge et plus il se prolonge et plus t'es mal à l'aise !
Bah ouais voilà tu sors le mot en français bon voilà pour casser ça ! On t'en veux pas Hollande…
MANUEL VALLS !
Manuel Valls, qui était premier le ministre quand François Hollande était Président de la République
Une fois il est passé sur France Inter, et il a eu une attitude trop bizarre
*musique angoissante qui monte crescendo*
*silence*
C'est un reptilien. Il avait entamé sa transformation. Il a su se ressaisir au dernier moment en regardant derrière lui
Et en secouant ses mains. Ce qui fait baisser la température du corps
On est pas passé loin d'un reptilien à la présidence !
Ah oui y'a une autre fois aussi il a fait un discours à l'assemblé et sa main gauche tremblait énooormément pendant le discours
Et tout le monde a remarqué ça et les gens ne savaient pas trop quoi en penser...
Voila par exemple elle, elle est perdue là
Derrièere, Ségolène, elle est perdue
*rires*
Il a des attitudes des fois en public qui font un peu flipper
Et même je trouve qu'il a une tête de méchant dans les films !
*extrait de Star Wars avec le discours de Valls derrière*
Alors je sais qu'on juge pas quelqu'un par sa tête, mais ça ne m'inspire pas confiance quoi.
Un homme politique, t'a besoin de lui faire confiance
Il est temps maintenant de parler d'un personnage que j'adore parce qu'on a l'impression qu'il n'a rien a faire là
qu'il s'est perdu, il s'est retrouvé là et il s'amuse
JEAN LASSALLE !
*rires*
Alors lui mec… Il a fait tellement de moments, où il fait n'importe quoi…
Mais je trouve que l'accent du sud, ça rend les gens sympa !
Alors même si des fois il parait misogyne sa mère, et bah on arrive pas à lui en vouloir et ça c'est un PROBLÈME !
Déjà, oh oui… oh oui ça je sais ce que c'est… Juste ça c'est fou
*une assemblé normale…*
*quelqu'un se met à chanter un chant bearnais*
Monsieur, svp ! SVP ! Vous pouvez vous asseoir et ne pas chanter dans cet hémicycle
Asseyez vous !
*il continue a chanter*
Monsieur !
Comment il s'appelle ah oui monsieur luiset
Vous pouvez vous asseoir ! svp !
*Squeezie rit*
est ce qu'un jour quelqu'un pensait qu'à l'Assemblée
quelqu'un dirait cette phrase
Asseyez vous et cessez de chanter *rire*
MAIS ON EST OU LA DANS UNE CLASSE DE 6ème !!!!
C'est qui votre cochon préféré ?
Mon cochon préféré ?
C'est une petite cochonne...
C'est qui ?
C'est mon épouse !
*rire*
Il a rigolé presque 5 secondes à sa propre blague
Qu'est-ce que j'aimerais pouvoir faire ça
*Il chante*
*Il chante* Mais mec mais voilà
Il aurait du faire carrière dans la chanson !
Il est à l'Assemblée, il voit des gens devant lui ça lui fait penser à une salle de concert
Il se lève il chante, c'est un artiste !
Voilà ce que c'est Jean Lassalle
Attendez, on ne voit pas trop mon décolleté !
….
Tu vas me mettre en forme avant le discours, toi !
*squeezie choqué*
Mec ! *rire* Ah! J'ai pas envie
de la commenter celle là !
Vous êtes ensemble ? Oui !
Quel joli couple ! Non c'est ma mère ...
Oh, ça alors !
Tu es toute jeunette ! *rire*
*rire* Oh ça alors !
Tu arrêtes avec les femmes maintenant
tu les laisses Jean Lassalle !
Merci beaucoup Jean Lassalle Merci !
Merci à vous !
Vous êtes une intervieweuse
Qui ferait parler un mort ...
*rire nerveux* C'est gentil ! Merci beaucoup
Le grand journal à la présidentielle ça continue...
Mesdames faites gaffes
à Jean Lassalle quand même
Aller on passe à un autre
J'appelle François Bayrou
Un jour il  rendait visite à une mairie
D'un quartier défavorisé il me semble
Sachant ça et sachant qu'il y avait des caméras il y a des jeunes
Qui ont lancé des pierres sur une vitre de la mairie
Pour qu'elle se pète et donc François Bayrou
sort de la mairie et parle à ces jeunes
Et mec il fait un truc exceptionnel
Mais pas dans le bon sens du tout
"Pendant la discussion quelques enfants
se massent autour du candidat"
*BAFFE*
*squeezie choqué*
Attendez attendez je remets la scène j'ai pas bien vu
*BAFFE*
*Oh oh oh oh*
"TU ME FAIT PAS LES POCHES !
SI, TU ME FAISAIT LES POCHES !
*voix de journaliste* L'incident n'ira pas plus loin."
*rire* Au calme
Je ris pas pour la gifle qu'il..c'est très grave
Mais pour tout ce qu'il y a autour c'est génial !
Déjà est-ce que ce gosse lui faisait vraiment les poches
On saura jamais !
Il est possible qu'il est sortit un gros mytho
Ou alors qu'il a cru que le gamin lui faisait les poches alors que non
Mais le plus fou c'est LUI !!
On dirait qu'il vient de voir un but
de la France en final de coupe du monde
alors que non il vient juste de voir son pote se faire gifler par un homme politique
*rire*
C'est quoi cette réaction mec c'est génial !
*musique*
*silence*
L'homme dont il ne faut pas dire le nom sous peine de bad buzz immédiat
*rire*
Alors lui mec il a fait un nombre de trucs...
C'est un truc de malade
Il est 100 fois plus connue pour ses gaffes,
que pour ses idées politiques, Ah vraiment. Regardez ça !
femme de la vidéo : Est ce que vous voyez des aspects positifs à l'immigration qui était la question, le.. 2 ème partie de la question.
Jean-Marie Lepen : Dans un certain sens oui !
Jean-Marie Lepen : Quand c'est, quand c'est.. Euh...
Jean-Marie Lepen : Bien sur, si c'est Léonard de Vinci c'est sûr !
*Huées du public* [ Lucas est complètement dépité par la réponse de cet homme...]
Jean-Marie Lepen : J'vais te faire courir moi, tu vas voir Rouquin va !
Jean-Marie lepen : Hein, P* ( insulte homophobe  )
[musique]
Je vais te faire courir moi Rouquin.
P* ( Insulte homophobe )
*bruit avec sa bouche*
Ssss... *souffle*
Heure..Heureusement ça c'est.. Aujourd'hui c'est pas impossible.
Mais heureusement quoi.
Jean-Marie Lepen : Moi, j'offre, un débat monsieur à Mélenchon
Jean-Marie Lepen : Et je vais lui retirer
Jean-Marie Lepen : EUUeuEU..
Jean-Marie Lepen : Son caleçon !
*Squeezie rigole par cette fin de phrase*
ça me dépasse je sais pas quoi dire..
Comment tu peux dire ça quand t'es dans le politique game ?
C'est fou
Jean-Marie Lepen : On a trouvé du sperme
Jean-Marie Lepen : dans les cheveux de Madame si il faut parler de les choses par leurs noms
Jean-Marie Lepen : Dans les cheveux de Madame Diallo.
Jean-Marie Lepen : ce n'est pas venu comme ça ce n'est pas un shampoing
Jean-Marie Lepen : Le shampoing Strauss-kahn.
*Squeezie rigole*
Jean-Marie Lepen : Bon.
[Musique avec Squeezie qui rigole mais on ne le voit pas car il veut pas qu'on voit qu'il a rigolé à une telle blague]
En fait je rit pas parce que c'est drôle en soit ce qu'il dit
Je ris parce que c'est ma seule réaction face à ce que je vois ça me dépite profondément *en rigolant* d'entendre ça !
*En imitant Jean-Marie Lepen* C'est pas un SHAMPOING !
Ou alors c'est le shampoing Strauss-Kahn Heiinnn ?!
[musique avec Squeezie réagissant à des gaffes de Jean-Marie Lepen*
[Fin de musique]
*destruction de la tête à Lucas dans 3!*
*2 !*
*1!*
*Explosion*
LES AMIS ! J'ai trop vu de moments politiques pour l'année !
*rire de fatigue*
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si elle vous à plu !
J'espère que ça ne partira pas en guerre d’opinions dans les commentaires
On n'est pas là pour ça ! Y'a des forum si vous voulez, Vraiment !
Je compte sur vous pour maintenir la bonne ambiance qu'il y a généralement  dans les commentaires des mes vidéos.
Moi en tout cas, je voulais montrer des trucs qui sont moins connus au près de nous et des plus jeunes même que moi
Parce que je trouve ça intéressent, je trouve ça marrant ça démystifie un peu le truc
Et puis si ça permet à des gens de s'intéresser derrière à la politique
Tant mieux c'est bien !
Y'a plein, plein, plein, PLEIN d'hommes politiques dont j'ai pas parlé là parce qu'il y avait rien d'incroyable sur eux.
J'ai pas fait des choix pour influencer mon public ou je sais pas trop quoi
Non, parce que là vraiment c'est un sujet vraiment tabou
Clément on annule tout FAIT PAS CE MONTAGES !
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo n'hésite pas à t'abonner si c'est pas fait et de liker !
Le nom des gens qui ont fait les sous-titres sont dans la description !
Allez vous abonner à leurs chaînes pour leur contributions ça leur ferait vraiment plaisir.!
Sinon la team de sous-titrage vous souhaite une bonne journée, fin de journée ou nuit.
On vous dit à la prochaine !
Ciao !